Buenas tardes Sí porque los partidos
como lo mencionabas fracasaron en esta
fecha límite de seis meses para formar
el gobierno probablemente esos nuevos
comicios regionales serán el 15 de
diciembre prestamos a la espera de que
la fecha sea plenamente conformada sin
embargo por la complejidad del asunto es
poco probable que las elecciones sea la
única solución el acuerdo de paz de 1998
que trajo Paz política a Irlanda del
Norte Establece que siempre en esta
región habrá Un gobierno de coalición
entre los republicanos del que arrasaron
por primera vez en la historia en las
elecciones de mayo y los unionistas el
partido unionista
bloquea estas negociaciones desde el
triunfo del chimpan para presionar al
gobierno central en Londres para que
modifique el protocolo de Irlanda del
Norte que mantiene a esta región
británica dentro del sistema de aduanas
el mercado único de la Unión Europea
pero esas modificaciones no dependen del
gobierno central en Londres sino de
Bruselas Es cierto que ha habido
negociaciones entre Londres y Bruselas
con varias polémicas como La amenaza del
gobierno desconocer este protocolo pero
lo cierto es que esta es ahora una tarea
aún más urgente para el Primer Ministro